oh my gosh
the christmas day explosion that shook
downtown nashville
remains much of a mystery the motive for
this bombing
and who is responsible have not been
confirmed
but the fbi is investigating a person of
interest
police were already on the scene
responding to reports of gunshots
and of a suspicious motorhome that was
captured on the move
five hours earlier the vehicle
then played a recorded voice message
warning anyone nearby
to clear the area three people were
injured in the explosion
human remains have been found but not
identified
officers responded to a shots fired call
and had
didn't have any idea what else was going
on the typical
police call and as they arrived they saw
an rv
that was giving out a message saying it
would detonate within 15 minutes a
countdown would go
music would play and instead of
taking it as just maybe a thread and
calling in and getting resources
they immediately began knocking on doors
they coordinated
the resources to get everyone evacuated
and out had they not done that we'd be
talking about
people as well with you know with the
destruction that we have
these cctv images appear to show the
moment of the explosion
which was felt nine blocks away and
heard for miles
investigators say they've received more
than 500 leads or tips from members of
the public
the explosion next to an at t telecoms
building
knocked out phone lines leaving some to
ask
if this was the intended target
this doesn't strike me as as a classical
uh terrorist attack uh in part because
uh it was not meant to generate uh mass
casualties
and what we've seen certainly in terms
of uh militia
attacks uh carried out in the united
states
they they have been intended to kill
a lot of people uh here uh the hour at
which
the the explosive was detonated uh the
fact that there was a warning in advance
all suggests that uh it was not a
serious terrorist attack
police haven't confirmed if anyone was
in the motor home when it exploded
but investigators say there is no
manhunt
and no active threat nashville may now
be safe
but it's left very shaken by this
terrifying act
sally lockwood sky news new york